trying to get away from F reron and a save
by Bennington pucked loose there now it's
white cloud lets it Go tipped and a great save
by Bennington on the rebound as well that was
right near the goal line as Nicholas W down below
looking to get a good scoring chance diving but
Jordan Bennington gets the paddle across pla Tire
goalie cam look at Jordan vinning from tracking
that Puck and then staying strong Alexander wins
the face off brunovich with the dump it played by
White Cloud now for hay and now Ki walks it out
here's dick W who is turned away to White Cloud
shoots it and he scores White Cloud into the
top corner is first of the year and it's one
nothing see the Blu here good back check by
tchenko little bit too much of a gap off the
blue line here then White Cloud goes short side
shelf I think Jordan Bennington was thinking pass
on this one here as he starts to lean a little
bit leaves that Top Shelf with a one nothing
lead now turned over at Center
neighbors com back in with B davish
neighbors right in he scores what a shot
by neighbors and the blues have tied to G
to your net as you look at Robert Thomas here
good stick Jake neighbors was hustling back at
the time Pavo bnavi going to the net then Jake
neighbors just dangles around drops the shoulder
to the middle here catches the goalie Cheon and
just chips it up over the shoulder that is a goal
scor goal look at the soft touch right here right
up over the shoulder that's all we need to say
right Andy couple of for Vikings uh talking about
that and yeah I've seen Kate at top call before
nice young man and did a great job today there the
blues come in drop pass here's Kyo to KR right in
front they score Kevin Hayes with a tip in what
a goal and the blues have taken a two to one
lead starting with blue go tender tape to tape
great Puck support Tory Krug the defenseman up
in the rush he gets it back and that's a that's a
OneTouch sweeper pass straight across the crease
look at this no on and off the stick that allows
Kevin Hayes to get inside position 3 minutes left
here in the first period this Prov Waits now from
Justin F Shanda Center Ice tyou to the middle wide
open he scores oh what a play unbelievable
goal by kyou and the blows lead three to
one opportunities he's had using his speed
and again good passing sets this up and
right here Jordan Kyrie the old shake
and bake to the middle of the ice and
how you going it's in the back of the net
and the young man very excited but what a
play look at that and then the presence of
mind right at the very end to just talk it
five on the wall comes to the middle of the ice
and now CER to the knights to Carlson he darts in
and a shot and a save by Bennington with his
walker off a stick it hit hton now stolen by
Oscar sunst to B davage oneon-one he comes in a
drive and a save by Thompson and petrangelo turns
it away from his checking now the knights back
to the line eel a good pass right across Carlson
in Fr l pad save another shot and it stays out
that was close I think benington got some hope
from his friends there spins it in deep Thomas
is there now Kyu gets it out in front which D
was wide open and a stick Sav by Thompson what a
set up there trying to make a play now for budic
waiting to crew right in a save by Thompson and
he juggles it this is Jack eel back in and the
former saber to the net tipped on goal and a
save by Bennington and now loose there bles
don't get it though here's eel shoots and he
scores and Jack EO a turnaround shot makes it
3-2 but right from the get go the golden Knight
were pressing here Jordan vinon with a big save
there then some good Puck retrievers by the
golden knights right there Jack iel pushes
out of the blue paint finds the loose puck in the
crowd and turns on the puck by himself some time
and space right there so he can get the shot off
and the clck rolls to Center ice and the Knights
get it pass back and Mato right in gets it again
and a great save by Bennington and now kept in
by petrula here's Stone in front Maro team pass
IO now he settles it watch there by B davish to
the goal line to Carlson right in front the
score and maraso is tied to game of three
eichel moves the puck down to Carlson Carlson
does a good job of spinning with momentum to the
front of the net his foot does kick the Stick
of Jordan Bennington and then marsho finds the
loose Puck and puts it in the back of the net
if we get a little closer here he knocked a
stick out of his hands here watch this he does
knock the stick out of his hands while skating
through the paint we'll see if we get a challenge
here and there was an incorrect challenge it's a
penalty so there is a risked ball now the KN
Center it hit by S kept in and now corac with
it to MF shoots and he scores and the Knights
have taken a 4 to3 lead with three in a row
here the golden knights don't do anything
special here the tenacious are on the pucks
get it up high shot on net and you got traffic
out in front and you know the Vegas golden kns
going to be parked up front they got those big
forwards that want to clear or crowd the net take
away the golender eyes McNab Waits gets it to the
net then kisar right there at the top of the blue
paint I think Craig bruy knows right away pass
back and Brun waiting finds scandella shot on
goal save by Thompson to Thomas back to Paro
he darts in shoots it gets his own rebound the
Breo in front to neighbors off the goal post
oh what a setup there Vegas enters cleanly ww
drops it off here's Hutton to pass to the far
Wing now settled by barf 22 to go in the period
now back for barers Shi to Stevenson rebound
they score and mtio a power play goal and it's
53 not exactly what you want here
the blues they gain the Zone entry
they're able to move the puck around
effectively here they get set up in
their 131 and then the rebound here goes
right back to amario Jordan Bennington
makes the save there probably like to
guide that rebound a little better but
amario and then fired ahead by by
Thomas kept in by pangela now the
knights in front Carlson rebound
attempt and a save by Bennington
Thomas and Carlson on the draw and the
Knights get it Carlson empty net and he
scores and William Carlson with his
12 that will seal the deal and it's
63 oh that's a tough one there
right off the draw here golden
knights just chip it past there
and then Carlson rips it down the
ice Carlson gets his 12th of the year
and now the blues go back on the road
for two more and a frustrated
coach buuy and the blues head off